welcome to this episode of our podcast
where we tackle important issues
affecting teenagers mental health and
what we can do to help I'm your host
Anna bra in today's episode we will look
into a crucial topic Teen Mental Health
in high school high school is a time of
growth and challenges and we want to
shine a light on the mental health
concern concerns that many teenagers
face and provide valuable insights on
how to manage them so let's begin by
understanding Teen Mental Health a
little bit better let's discuss why it's
essential to address Teen Mental Health
high school can be a very exciting yet
very stressful period in our life where
very often teenagers are confused about
what they want for themselves and who
they want to be since during this time
is when we start to build a character
Studies have shown that most if not
almost all of high school students
experience mental health issues such as
depression anxiety PTSD and so on and it
is very important to shed light into
these mental health issues by noticing
the signs and helping someone in need
let's talk about signs and symptoms
recognizing the signs and symptoms of
teen mental health issues is vital
common indicators include changes in
Behavior mood swings and withdrawal from
social activities sometimes you may
notice your peers drifting away from
something they used to enjoy like sports
or studies being laid to class often
distancing from people having a mindset
that nothing really matters these are
some subtle yet notice able signs that
someone is going through something very
challenging in life and need help with
their mental health it's important to
remember that each individual's
experience is unique and helping them
find a way of coping with these issues
especially during this period is more
than enough to make a difference in
someone's life now let's explore some
practical coping strategies that high
school students can use to manage their
mental health some coping strategies
that have helped out a lot of teenagers
could be like seeing a therapist talking
to a school counselor balancing your
time by making a schedule and so on It's
always important to remember that when
somebody is going through a hard time
it's normal to be burnt out emotionally
and physically sometimes you might find
yourself not having energy to do basic
task and it's important to take your
time with yourself and work on being a
better version of yourself and it's good
to find healthy coping mechanisms and
seeking help when it's needed to provide
a real life perspective I have reached
out to people I know and talked about
their experience in high school and how
it affected them so today I will be
inviting a guest to tell us more about
her experience in high school
hello everyone I'm your guest Elisa braa
so Elisa tell us a little bit about your
high school experience and how it
affected your mental health my high
school experience I can say it was like
anyone's normal high school experience
except we had Co 19 back then and it was
a little hard harder than usual and we
all had some kind of fear of missing out
in the first year we we felt like our
best years or adolescent years were just
going down the drain and and it was a
lot stressful with the stress of
everyone getting sick our exam getting
exams all getting piled up and what will
happen in the future and I can say that
most of my peers including me had some
problems during that stage we had some
anxiety some even depression and we had
different ways to deal with it so how
did it feel when you went back to normal
life in
school it didn't feel real we were all
so excited but then it hit us it's just
we back to reality high school was not
it it was not like everybody made it out
to be it was a lot of of stress during
your exams a lot of stress with your
peers trying to fit in and with your
imagination for your further education
in University what would you say was the
most stressful part about high school
that might have caused your mental
health to go a little backwards maybe I
can say for myself it was maybe my
applications in University in the last
last year uh they were really stressful
and besides having my applications I
also had like my M exam which is like um
the national exam we take we our
graduation our prom and I had everything
piled up it was a lot more stressful
than the years before so how would you
um come to the conclusion that high
school was your best years or maybe your
worst years I can't say neither of them
them they were not definitely not the
best years but not the worst years
either they were good I had fun I
learned lots of new stuff I meet lots of
new friends it was an experience I don't
want to go back to but an experience
that grew me as a person do you have any
regrets from high school no I do not
have any regrets I like the way my house
my high school experience went even
though it didn't go as planned okay
thank you so much so now that we talked
with our Our Guest about her High School
experience I would like to talk about
breaking the stigma let's discuss the
importance of breaking the stigma
surrounding mental health open
conversation and education can help
create a more supportive environment in
high schools encouraging those in need
to seek help without hesitation because
often topics related to mental health
are pushed aside and labeled as just a
face and a lot of times mental health
issues start small and progressively get
worse if not treated with the right
amount of attention which is why I
believe it's important to be an open
topic for more teenagers to be well
educated about how they can work through
it or help others going through it we
reached out to some of our listeners and
received some fantastic questions about
Teen Mental Health so let's address a
few of them the first question was what
do you think is the biggest cause of bad
mental health for teenagers I personally
think that most of the time teenagers in
high school when they first begin it's a
new environment for everybody it's um a
lot of new students a lot of new
teachers and a lot of um
new uh more stressful Vibes because you
have the pressure of making new friends
making memories you don't really want to
miss out on the experience of high
school by not making friends the first
few weeks so beginning there is just um
you get Nostalgia from primary school
when you think about your friends when
you think about how it used to be and
that it all changed and I think what
really affects uh teenagers is how fast
everything changes and how um hard it is
to adapt to those changes the second
question was why do teenagers not go to
their parents for their issues I think
that most teenagers um when they get to
a certain age they no matter how small
or how big the issue is most of the time
they're more closed off because they
don't really um want anybody to see the
stress and um maybe push it aside or
maybe some in my case and in a lot of
teenagers cases they don't usually go to
um adults for their issues because they
don't feel like they understand the
third question was what are the best
ways to help someone in need well it
really depends on the situation and how
bad the mental health can be because if
it's um minor stress or no matter what
type of mental health conditions you
might have it's always going to be a
very important subject so whatever you
need whenever you need help or something
there's always a therapist you can go to
a counselor friends family anybody and I
will always encourage people to wake up
with a fresh mindset so no matter how
burnt out you are to always try and do
something small that will lift up your
energy and give you more motivation and
every day something small will lead to
something even bigger the more you work
on yourself and with time everything
will get better now with all the
questions that have been answered with
the guest um finishing what she had to
say and with everything that I have said
so far we hope that this episode have sh
has shed light on the significance of
Teen Mental Health in high school
remember if you or someone you know is
struggling it's okay to seek help reach
out to a trusted adult school counselor
or therapist you're not alone in this
journey thank you for joining us today
we're dedicated to raising awareness and
offering support for Teen Mental Health
stay tuned for more episodes and please
share this podcast with those who might
benefit your mental health matters so
take care and we'll see you in the next
episode